at this point you'll expect Cersei to
die by the hand of fear her brother
Jaime or Daenerys Targaryen and her
dragons however in this video I'm
bringing no fear if mining which Cersei
will actually be betrayed and killed by
her most trusted people basically Qyburn
has this whole time been working for
various send a mountain will be traced
her soon chi burns over and they'll put
an end to the math queen as she's her
own worst enemy and that mountain will
talk again
there's plenty of proof clothes hints
and even some filming leagues are
supporting this theory of mine so let's
just jump in it from the very beginning
since the very first episode Qyburn
appeared on show they were raising more
and more yet and explained and
unanswered questions for example why did
Qyburn even decide to save the mountains
life life of the same man that severely
injured him almost killed him
shun dating friends okay
lucky as I'm sure most of us remember
for unknown reasons sky burn ended up
among the northern and Riverlands
prisoners at Harrenhal surely after Sir
Gregor could gain a ban on the castle on
his all captives put to the sword
Qyburn however survives the injury at
his throat and the vacants of the castle
is taken by the northern army after he
wakes he identified himself to Robb
Stark while Tallis attends to his wound
so Khyber saving the mountains life who
back in the third season almost kill him
is strange to say least another strange
fact is skyrim being able to use spy
capabilities of same little birds that
very used in previous seasons in case
you're wondering how can I be so sure
that Piper's little birds are the ones
that used to work for various it was
confirmed in season 6 episode 3 no I
don't think so you miss him he was nice
he called us as little birds
he gave us sweets it's funny you should
mention that that's what I happen to
find today now remember if any of your
friends like sweets will need help they
can always come to me all I need in
return similar birds they were
Centurions concern about their loyalty
replied with men can be fickle but bird
Silas just from this conversation we can
see the various fully believes his
little birds and bears can be considered
as everything but a fool additionally
verse is known as a man of knowledge and
whispers as a man that knows every step
of every living man in the Seven
Kingdoms Varys fully trusts someone that
someone will not betray him even if that
would mean the death were that someone
in case didn't know little birds his
verses found a group of spies which he
educates give sweets and provides them
with protection in return for the
information they bring him his
sophisticated intelligence network which
is one of the largest in the world and
span
both Westeros and Essos due to his vast
web of intelligence sources verse is
known as the spider this fact gives me
even more doubt about where it's not
knowing about a group of six pies that
supposedly betrayed him all of this
means that Qyburn is most likely working
for very soon is waiting for the right
time to be traced Searcy and
orchestrated her death as we all know
Qyburn thirst became extremely close
considering the fact that served
situated people around her specially the
just right one said paranoia and
suspicious thoughts
Qyburn however gained search his full
trusted bringing Clegane back to life
after he was severely wounded during his
fight against Oberyn Martell after death
Cersei named Qyburn as master whispers
as the varices replacement on a small
Council the thing is that even if Qyburn
managed to bribe few versus all birds
and even if those few spice agreed to
betray Varys there's simply no way that
first wouldn't find it out there is no
way that none of his little birds
wouldn't send whisper to him if sure if
cabin truly does work for various this
would also raise a few important
questions I'm sure you're wondering if
Qyburn a little birds are loyal to we're
sweaty little birds in phone Qyburn
about wildfire who later informed Cersei
about it which led to annihilation of
the great Sept of Baelor along with all
sources enemies before I give you an
answer on that question let me just
highlight one fact that you all have to
know before we continue
where's has been loyal to House
Targaryen all the time Varys has been
serving Danny's father as well he was
one of the small amount of people who
served Mad King even when it was obvious
that he was going to lose the war he
nurses final days having arrived at
King's Landing with an entire Lannister
army in his back verse warned the king
not to open the gates which chefs
refused because of a grand maester
pycelle who told Matt King what he
wanted to hear Aysel told him that
timing can be trusted that timing came
to save the day this resulted with the
Mad King opening the city gates which
resulted with the city being sacked and
aris himself being stabbed in the back
by Jaime
verse has been working on a plan to
bring to the nearest Inn House Targaryen
back the Iron Throne that has been taken
from them since the fall House Targaryen
here we come to our ends to run a
question which was if Qyburn and little
birds are loyal to very sweaty little
birds inform Qyburn about wildfire who
later informed Cersei an answer and that
question is actually very simple
search his plan to destroy the great
Sept of Baelor along with all important
people in it match perfectly with vs.
plan additionally I think we're sexually
ordered Qyburn and his all birds to find
out if the Wildfire actually is under
the great Sept of Baelor and if it
really is to inform Cersei about it
immediately
Varys is quite a smart man he
aware that if sir suppose to wipe out
most of the leadership with wildfire
it will resulted with her losing all her
allies and it woulda made a nice
conquest far easier and in fact that is
exactly what happened Qyburn informed
sirs about wildfire knowing into the
results just away dead just as varus
expected Cersei wiped out all her
enemies and Elias which gave him an
opportunity to make new allies for Dany
in this case with Olenna Tyrell says he
stole the future from me she killed my
son
she killed my grandson she killed my
granddaughter survival is not what I'm
after now you're absolutely right I
chose the wrong words it is not survival
I offered it is your heart's desire and
what is my heart's desire vengeance
justice
fire and blood by the sack verse with
Qyburn self managed to provide a new
ally for his queen and made the nurses
take over even easier also the fact that
Qyburn brought will gain back to life
who back in third season slit his throat
and almost kill him is something that I
cannot get over it would only make sense
if it's a part of a bigger plan of
vengeance it could be the tyrant created
monster only to get even closer to
Cersei which would allow them when the
time comes to easily kill Cersei while
she thinks that he's her most trusted
protector as the mountain monster closes
that the only guard throughout the past
few seasons it's a to say he will
continue to be in the final season as
well
if Qyburn truly works for berries then
some of the main characters might still
be alive in season 7 episode 3 searching
prison Silurian 10 gives me a kiss of
death
thinking she poisoned her a bit later in
same episode now Jamie gives Elena
poison leaves thinking he poisoned her
did they really die matter of fact were
they even poisoned no Qyburn is the one
providing the supposed poison to Cersei
in the cells the supposed poisoned Jamie
gives to Elena is also most likely
coming from Qyburn since his Lannister's
maester was there really a poison or was
it yet another master plan of the
cunning spider Raiders if Qyburn is
working for various not only what it
proved once again how brilliant versus
mind really is but it will arguably be
the greatest waste in the game of
Thrones show Cersei would be betrayed
and killed by her most trusted advisor
Qyburn and protect her the mountain
while salmon characters would turn out
to be alive and well there are even some
season 8 filming news that could be
going favor to this theory Almodovar del
Rio Kastle in Cordoba Spain will return
in Game of Thrones Season 8 which means
they will revisit the Tyrells stronghold
well an ass Castle reappearing in season
8 even though she's supposedly dead
isn't the strangest part however though
we will see the castle Game of Thrones
is not filming there again multiple
sources confirmed that the production we
used leftover footage from the first
Almodovar shoot in 2016 for season 7
this means that there will not be any
new filming at Amador Del Rio but the
production will use scenes they filmed
for season 7 could it be that the scene
we are going to see has something to do
with Elena perhaps for watching Jamie
Lannister and armies marching back home
while they think they just poison her in
conclusion all those theories combined
with all the proofs in said clothes
would most certainly make the greatest
face in the game of turn show and it
also seems like something that the
showrunners would pull out to leave us
the touch of speechless in the season
finale does this mean that the popular
Jamie killing stirs the theory will not
come true no as a matter of fact I don't
expect hibernal Varys or even any of the
characters that search they think she
killed that could be allowed to put an
end on sources rain
I still think Jamie's great as the it is
going to be killing Cersei to prevent
her from burning down the entire capital
Jamie Lannister
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds best of time is that for a
four-year-old knight with one hand
however even the two handed Jamie will
have trouble passing by the mountain to
come closer see but considering that
Jamie has been brave and fearless his
entire life no matter that he lost his
saying he will try to kill both the
mountain and Cersei of course the Jamie
most likely wouldn't be able to pass by
Sir Gregor Clegane he probably wouldn't
stand a chance against the mountain
who's near death only made him stronger
in this very moment I expect the final
twist to happen the mountain on chi
burns order instead of killing Jaime and
defending Cersei will actually help
Jaime kill the Queen's Guard and put an
end to Cersei they wouldn't learn that
Qyburn has this whole time been working
for various well some characters that
Cersei thinks she killed with poison
that Qyburn provided would actually turn
out to be alive and well